so we're going to wash the potatoes very
well you can feel them or not that's up
to you if you don't feel that you have
to really watch them very very very well
and then time yeah you want to make
slices it's aa tiny bit of salt not a
mascota we will do the same thing will
be not you're not know he's very good
also just in a solid rock you can just
wash it and chop it and eat it with a
tiny bit of olive oil involved and
and then we do the same so we are going
to yes that's right
what we're doing we roll it and then we
seal it with a toothpick then I put
these little rose again in a baking pan
car with some milk
that's it so yeah
the oven and then we want the other side
yeah and then we add the like this much
okay okay and we just we offer the
definitive loop end of a car so in total
they will say in the Omega something
like 25 minutes home it depends on if
they are more or less 20 to 30 minutes
we want to be sure that it's well cooked
so its first part without the milk
you
member